c'est toujours instinctive le travail
artistique
vous savez c'est on sait plus qui a dit
ça on passe devant une caserne et on
voit une fenêtre allumé et on a écrit un
livre de 300 pages sur la vie militaire
et c'est toujours comme ça c'est à dire
que tout le monde est face à un tout
petit point de départ et puis après ça
c'est autre chose et en même temps un
artiste raconte toujours plus ou moins
la même histoire
moi je crois beaucoup que en tout cas un
pain de mon genre c'est quelqu'un qui a
eu effectivement une sorte de choc
premier ou d'histoire première qui est
donc arrivé dans l'enfance et qui peut
arriver plus tard et après ça toute sa
vie on ne cesse de raconter la même
chose mais ya pas de réel changement moi
je suis frappé par exemple que j'ai fait
un petit livre 68 69 et qu'en fait dans
ce petit livre que j'ai 69 il ya tout
mon travail j'ai rien inventé depuis
donc je vous parlais dernier vous vous
avez sali ma vie privée
les images de votre enfant la vistule
est classé retrouver en quelque sorte
que vous avez vécu tous les thèmes qui
m'ont intéressé par la suite comme par
exemple la la j'ai pas ce que j'appelle
la petite mémoire se trouvent déjà là
vous savez ce qu'il appelle la petite
mémoire c'est d'éclat avec en mémoire et
dans les livres
et puis ils acquittent mémoire c'est de
savoir où sont les meilleurs quiche
lorraine à paris quelques histoires
drôles eux c'est ce que nous sommes et
quand quelqu'un meurt ce qui est
toujours affreux c'est que cette petite
mémoire disparaît totalement et ce qui
nous différencie les uns les autres et
ses petites histoires c'est ce que nous
sommes et donc d'essayer de préserver
cette mémoire qui est en fait impossible
à préserver parce que c'est tellement
liés à chaque être humain a toujours été
une chose qui m'a intéressé de sa dose
de sauver ces bribes de vie
il ya toujours cette chose étrange que
quand quelqu'un meurt au bout de très
peu de temps
il ne reste vraiment plus rien
[Musique]
il ya quelqu'un qui avait dit une chose
que je trouvais jolie il y avait des
bons on meurt aujourd'hui deux fois mon
humeur quand on meurt vraiment et on
meurt quand encore une photo de vous et
qu'on sait plus qui sait
[Musique]
et
m
toute une partie de mon activité a été
sur de combat tout à fait grotesque qui
était de sauver cette mémoire et donc
des choses totalement insignifiante de
liquide ou qui nous font et photographie
de classe des vêtements ou des objets du
quotidien une brosse à dents whisky
toujours très étrange c'est qu'on est
tous ensemble avait tellement différent
avec eux je crois que ce qui est
important pour moi c'est de savoir qu'on
est tous différents et uniques c'est à
dire que il ya toujours ce problème par
exemple avec je sais pas les hommes
politiques ils peuvent dire on va faire
une guerre il y aura deux mille morts
c'est pas très grave
c'est pas beaucoup mais en fait c'est
pas de 1000 personnes qui meurent 5e
spaghettis l'autre capital mis au
troisième qui est un joueur de football
je c'est toujours un plus un plus un
plus un et être existé c'est justement
cela c'est être différent et donc la
petite mémoire c'est sauver cette
différence sauver le fait que bush que
moi en compte quelqu'un qui a une
passion pour les papillons puis il n'a
rien fait mais une passion pour les
papillons et toute sa vie a été liée à
cela est ce qu'on peut dire que vous
êtes un explorateur des traces du vivant
je me souviens notamment d'une
exposition de vous vous aviez mis dans
une chapelle sur le sol de la chapelle
des vêtements et par les personnes qui
rentraient devaient marcher
il est certain pour moi en tout cas et
je crois que ces choses réelles que le
avec moi usagers avec mon portée est
comme un corps moi je suis toujours très
touché par les vêtements usagés parce
qu'il ya encore les plis de la personne
qui la portait et puis il n'ya plus
cette personne donc une sorte d' axa
asia ya l'odeur oui et donc pour moi une
photographie de quelqu'un avec moi ou un
corps mort sont pas ce qui va lancer il
y avait quelqu'un il ya eu quelqu'un
mais maintenant c'est parti
j'ai souvent travaillé avec des
vêtements et je pense toujours tout ce
que j'ai fait à paris au quai de la gare
est également à new york dans une église
qui était de vendre des vêtements usagés
ou un prix très très bas donc je faisais
livrer une tonne de vieux vêtements
qu'ils étaient disposés lanta et tout le
monde pouvait les acheter
lobo il y avait un travail dit long sur
l'idée de calcul d'oeuvres d'art c'est à
dire que pour ceux qui savent écouter un
artiste ces dispositions le tas de
vêtements a été l'homme d'un station d
éthique et pour la plupart des gens qui
venaient c'est seulement à un endroit on
pouvait acheter des vêtements donc ça
m'intéressait mais il y avait aussi
quelque chose qu'il est d'un ordre plus
religieux qui était et celui de la
résurrection
c'est à dire que y'a un vêtement qui est
rejetée qui refusait qu'on ne veut plus
ou qui est un vêtement d'un mort et puis
quand quelqu'un leur achète ce vêtement
va de nouveau être aimé il va de nouveau
avoir une nouvelle vie et il ya une
sorte de beauté d'une marché aux puces
pour sa de ces objets qui sont morts qui
ont été oubliés et brusquement qui vont
de nouveau être aimé donc en tout cas le
vêtement pour moi est vraiment très très
lié à l'idée de de l'être humain cesser
sa peau
[Musique]